what i want to do in this video is
figure out if there's any
fast way to figure out the sum of the
roots of any polynomial and actually we
there actually is and so that's why i'm
doing this video so let's start with the
second degree polynomial so let's say
it's x squared plus
a 1 x
plus
a 2 is equal to 0. so this is just a
standard set quadratic equation right
here second degree equation and you
might be saying hey would you put the
coefficient on the x term being equal to
one and in general you can always
convert you can always convert any
any polynomial i'll do it with a second
degree but if you have ax squared plus b
x
plus c is equal to zero you can just
divide both sides of this equation by a
by a and you're going to have something
that's in this form where the
coefficient on the x squared term is
going to be equal to one you can do that
with any polynomial you can do that with
any polynomial that's set equal to zero
so with that out of the way let's think
about the sum of the roots of this are
going to be so this is a second degree
this is a second degree polynomial it's
a quadratic equation so it'll have two
roots they could be real or complex
so let's call the roots r1
and r2 and that tells us that these are
roots that x
minus r1 times x minus r2 is going to be
equal to zero and if we multiply this
out we get x times x is x squared
x times negative r 2 is negative r 2 x
neg and then we have negative r 1 times
x so negative r 1 x and then we have
negative r 1 times negative r2 which is
plus
r1 r2 is equal to zero and we can
simplify this middle term a little bit
it becomes x squared
minus r1 plus r2 r1 plus r2
x
plus
r1 r2 is equal to zero so let's think
about what the sum of the roots are so
based on what we're looking at right
over here what is r1 plus r2
well we see it right over here when we
when we multiplied out these two
expressions
r1 plus r2 is the negative of this
second coefficient right over here or
it's the negative of the coefficient
that on the first degree term so if we
look at the first degree term over here
a1
a1 must be the same thing as negative r1
as negative r1 plus r2 or another way to
think about it is r1 plus r2 must be
equal to
negative a1 so that wasn't too bad for
the second degree case let's try the
third degree case let's try let's see if
we have
x to the third plus a1
x squared plus a2 x plus a3 is equal to
zero let's think about let's think about
what the sum of its roots might be well
this guy is now going to have one more
root i'm not saying it's the exact same
equation but let's say we're keeping
everything general so now we can say we
have roots r1
r2 and r3 or we could say that x minus
r1 times x minus r2
times x minus r3
is equal to
0. now we could multiply all of this out
but we already figured out we already
figured out what x minus r1 times x
minus r2 is it's this business it's this
business over here so we just have to
multiply this times x minus r three and
actually i'm not even going to do the
full expansion because we have a hunch
here that something it always deals it
seems with with the with the coefficient
on the term that's one degree lower than
the degree of the polynomial this was
the second degree we looked at the
coefficient on the first degree term
maybe to find the sum we only have to
look at this coefficient over here so
i'm only going to figure out this
product up to this point and then we can
just we can just ignore the rest of it
and see if we get something that is
useful
so let's do the expansion let's multiply
this right over here
times this
over here and what do we get so we could
get the x
to get the x to the third term the only
way to get that is to multiply this x to
multiply this x times this x squared so
we're going to get x to the third
and then when you multiply and then and
that's the only way to get the x to the
third term that's the only we get the
third degree term now how do we get this
term over here how do we get let me do
this in a new color how do we get the x
squared term over here well we could
multiply this x times this over here
times this
term right over here because the x times
the x is going to give us x squared so
it'll be negative
r 1 plus r 2
x squared times that term and then if
you multiply this x times that you'll
get r 1 r 2 x and all of that but i'll
just write bob you know so on and so
forth and then what other ways can we
get an x squared term here there's no
other way to get an x to the third term
but what other ways can we get an x
squared term well when we do the when we
multiply this times this you have the
negative r 3. let me do this in another
color
we have you have the negative r3 times
this you're obviously going to take this
term and multiply it by everything and
then add it to this term multiplied by
everything but we only care about the
things you know i did this just to show
you that it's there but i only care
because we have a hunch that what
matters is the coefficient of the x
squared term so we just want to see how
do you build the x squared term in our
in our i guess our expanded polynomial
so if you have the only the other way to
get an x square is to multiply the
negative r 3 times this x squared over
here so this is going to be negative
r 3 times x squared and then when you
multiply this times this you're going to
get something else and when you multiply
this times this you're just going to get
the negative product of all the roots so
that's just something else and so when
we add everything together
when we add everything together you get
x to the third and then what's the sum
of these two things it's negative
r1 plus r2
plus r3
x squared and then you're just going to
have a bunch of other stuff that we
didn't take the time to add but it looks
like our hunch paid off because what is
now the sum of the roots
r1 plus r2 plus r3 what is that equal to
well that's sitting right over here
that's equal to the negative of this
coefficient right over here that's once
again equal to negative a1 it's equal to
the negative the negative of the
coefficient on the degree term that's
one less than one less than the degree
of our polynomial so we already see a
pattern let's see if we can prove it
generally let's prove it see if we can
prove it generally so we've already
proven essentially two base cases we've
proven it for a degree of two a degree
of three
let's assume that it's true for a degree
of n and then we can prove it for a
degree of n plus 1 and essentially this
will be a proof by induction for
polynomials of any degree so let's just
assume
so let's just say we have an nth degree
polynomial so let's just assume this
so we're going to assume this step and
this gives us a little proof by
mathematical induction practice so let's
just assume that we have a polynomial x
to the n it's nth degree so x to the n
plus a 1 x to the n minus 1 and it just
goes on and on and on all the way down
to the zeroth degree term it has roots
it has roots obviously r1 r2
all the way to
r sub n and we're going to assume we're
going to assume
that
r1 plus r2
plus all the way to r sub n is equal to
negative a1 is equal to negative a1 or
another way to to think about it if we
were to multiply
if we were to multiply x minus r1 times
x minus r2 and just keep multiplying all
the way to x minus r sub n is equal to
zero this should give us x to the n
minus r one plus r two plus all the way
to rn
all the way to r and x to the n minus
one and then plus a bunch of other stuff
that we're not going to calculate so
this this tells us this that this
this coefficient right over here is
going to be equal to this right over
here so that is what we are going to
assume
so now let's think about so now let's
so now let's and this we're not assuming
this part so now let's think about given
that let's think about
let's think about the situation where we
have a polynomial x to the n plus 1 plus
a 1 x to the n plus and it just keeps
going you get all of the degree terms
there so now this is going to have the
roots r1 r2
all the way to rn and then it'll have rn
plus 1. so it'll have all the it'll have
these n roots and then we'll have an r n
plus one so essentially that tells us
that
we're going to have
essentially if this product times r
minus or times x minus r n plus one is
equal to zero let me write it out i
don't want to skip steps so this tells
us if these are all the roots that x
minus r1
times x minus r2 blah blah blah blah all
the way to x minus rn
times x minus rn plus 1 is going to be
equal to 0. it has one more root than
the previous example than the one where
we made the assumption so if we were to
expand this thing out how can we do that
well this thing if we were to multiply
it out if we were to multiply it out
it's just this thing over here times
this new binomial because this thing
over here is
let me instead of let me use color coded
this thing let me do a different color
this thing over here we already
established we assumed is this thing
over here which is this thing over here
so if we want this entire expansion we
just have to multiply this
times this
so how can we get an x to the n plus one
term how can we get to the x x to the n
plus one term well there's only way
there's only one way to get the x to the
n plus one term and that's by
multiplying this x
times this x to the n
so that will give us x
to the n
x to the n plus 1. that's the only way
to do it that's the only way to get this
highest degree term now how can we get
how can we get let me do it in purple
how can we get it the x to the n term
how can we get the x to the n term well
we can multiply this x times this second
term over here so if you multiply this x
times this business over here you're
going to get negative
r1 plus r2 plus all the way to
rn x times x to the n minus 1 is just
going to be x to the n and then
obviously you're going to multiply this
x times all the other terms you're just
going to get a bunch of other stuff so
that's how we can get these two terms
using the x and then can we get either
of these degree terms using the r times
or the r sub n plus 1. well we can
multiply
we can multiply r sub n plus 1 or
negative r sub n plus 1 times x to the n
and then we'll also get a similar degree
term so we'll have negative
r sub n plus 1 times x to the n
and then obviously we're going to
multiply this times all of the other
characters in this polynomial so you're
going to have all this plus so on and so
forth but this will suit our purposes
because when you add these two things
what do we get
we get
x to the n plus one
and then we get minus
well these are this and this are the
coefficients on the x to the n
term so this is going to be minus
r1 plus r2 plus all the way to
plus rn and then this is minus rn plus 1
we have the minus out front so this is
plus r sub n plus 1 x to the n and then
we're going to have a bunch of a bunch
of other
lower degree terms that don't matter but
we've just proven our case what is
what is r1
r1 plus r2 plus all the way to plus r
sub n plus 1. what is this equal to well
in our expansion we have it right over
here that's equal to that over there
that is equal to the negative of this
coefficient it's equal to the negative
it's equal to the negative of a 1. and
the reason why this works out no matter
what even you know you say hey if i have
complex roots how does it always end up
being a real number and that's because
the imaginary parts cancel out when you
take their sum so let's just apply it
we've proven it we've proven actually
two base cases we've proven it for
a degree two for degree three and then
we show that if it's true for any degree
n then it's definitely true for any
degree n plus one so we know if it's
true for degree three then it's
definitely
true for degree four which means it's
definitely true for degree five so when
you a mathematical induction is kind of
this domino proof that if it's true for
three which makes it true for four then
making assuming it's true for four makes
it true for five and it just keeps going
to any end
so in general if someone gives you a
polynomial let me think of some crazy
polynomial if i were to give you x
squared and let me do it x to the
seventh
minus
minus pi x to the sixth plus e
x to the fifth
minus square root of two x to the fourth
minus i'll i won't write out all the
terms so minus three is equal to zero
someone were to give you this polynomial
and they would say what do the seven
roots of this polynomial add up to you
say oh well the sum of these roots is
going to be the negative of this
coefficient right over here so r1 plus
r2 plus all the way to r7
all seven roots are going to add up to
the negative of this coefficient they're
going to be equal to pi and one other
thing you might be saying hey wait every
polynomial you did had a one coefficient
in front of the highest degree term you
know not all polynomials have that and
the answer there is let's see if i were
to give you a polynomial
i don't know
seven
x to the fifth
minus
six x to the fourth plus
plus i don't know pi x to the third plus
a bunch of other stuff is equal to zero
and you want to find the sum of the of
this polynomial's roots you first divide
everything by seven so it becomes x to
the fifth
minus six over seven x to the fourth
plus pi over
seven x to the third plus so on and so
forth is equal to zero over seven which
is a zero and now you look at this
polynomial the sum is going to be
the negative of this coefficient here so
it's going to be the sum of all five
roots there's going to be six
over seven anyway hopefully you enjoyed
that